Kommen wir zum Ohrenanlegen. Ohrenanlegen, ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Manöver.
Wir können rechts und links Fläche einklappen. Zuallererst einmal kleine Ohren anlegen.
Mit angelegten Ohren und Beschleuniger schaffen wir Sinkgeschwindigkeiten von 3 bis Maximum 3,7 Meter pro Sekunde sinken.
Aber wir fliegen dabei geradeaus. Das heißt, wir haben noch einen Vorwärtsflug und können so beispielsweise aus irgendeinem Bereich, wo wir rauswollen, flüchten.
Also sehr effektiv und sehr gut und sehr einfach. Deshalb so ich.
Durch Anlegen der Ohren, also das könnt ihr euch eh merken, alles was klappt, bremst zuallererst einmal den Schirm.
Wenn wir das von der Seite betrachten, durch Anlegen der Ohren haben wir jetzt Fläche verringert.
Wir bremsen den Schirm rechts und links auf den äußeren Flügeln ein bisschen ab.
Das heißt, unser Anstellwinkel erhöht sich jetzt.
Jetzt ist das für uns ein bisschen schlecht, weil mit dem erhöhten Anstellwinkel sind wir natürlich langsamer geworden.
Wir haben durch die geringere Fläche eine erhöhte Flächenbelastung.
Also unser Gewicht ist immer noch gleich geblieben.
Das heißt, das Gewicht pro Quadratmeter Fläche ist deutlich größer als vorher.
Das bedeutet, dass wir jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr Fläche haben.
Das bedeutet auch, dass der Stallpunkt, also der Punkt, wo wir den Schirm am Vorwärtsflug hindern, dass der auch nach oben gewandert ist.
Also der ist höher geworden.
Ich mache nur ein Beispiel, das stimmt nicht mit der Realität, aber einfach, dass ihr das Ganze ein bisschen nachvollziehen könnt.
Mit geöffnetem Schirm sind wir beim Stallpunkt von 18 bis 20 kmh.
Mit angelegten Ohren und größerer Flächenbelastung sind wir bei 24, 23 bis 25 kmh.
Und bei dieser Fläche sind wir in der Fläche als Flaschenbelastung.
Jetzt sind wir aber langsamer geworden durch den erhöhten Anstellwinkel.
Das bedeutet, unser Fenster, wo vorher so groß war zum Stallpunkt, ist jetzt kleiner geworden.
Also der Abriss ist viel einfacher möglich.
Zudem ist es ja oft so, dass man die Ohren dann noch ein bisschen aufpupfen möchte und der Abriss einfach viel schneller vorhanden ist.
Das kombiniert mit zum Beispiel Thermik wäre dann auch noch fatal.
Grund gibt es bei uns in der Schulung Ohrenanlegen immer nur in Verbindung mit dem Beschleuniger.
Denn durch das Beschleunigen neige ich die Kappe vorne weiter nach unten, ich verringere
also den Anstellwinkel, ich erhöhe sogar noch mal die Sinkgeschwindigkeit und ich bin
jetzt mit meinem, oder mein Abrissfenster, das ist jetzt wieder etwas größer geworden.
Also ich habe wieder mehr Distanz zum Stallpunkt. Und deshalb gibt es bei uns Ohrenanlegen immer
nur in Verbindung mit dem Beschleuniger. Gut, wie machen wir das Ganze? Ohrenanlegen,
eigentlich sehr simpel, wir behalten die Bremse am Steg in der Hand, wir richten uns den Beschleuniger,
wer nicht so einfach in den Beschleuniger reinkommt, kann die Bremse auch in eine Hand
nehmen und sich dann den Beschleuniger richten. Dann gehen die Bremsen aber wieder in die jeweilige
Hand über. Dann sollen wir mal den Beschleuniger treten, sodass wir mit beiden Beinen schön
symmetrisch leicht drinnen stehen, 30 bis 40 Prozent. Jetzt versuchen wir uns zu orientieren,
wir suchen die äußerste A-Leine. Die geht auf der A-Ebene einfach weit nach außen
zum Schirm, geht aber nicht zum Flügelende vom Schirm. Das wäre die Stabilo-Leine und
die ist meistens auf der B-Ebene vorzufinden. Hier in meinem Fall hat sie auch eine andere
Farbe wie die restlichen Leinen auf der B-Ebene. Manchmal jedoch ist es farblich vom Hersteller
nicht sehr klug gewählt. Wir haben auch schon gehabt, dass die äußerste Stabilo-Leine
die Farbe passend, also identisch mit der A-Ebene war. Also auf der A-Ebene waren alle
Leinen rot und die Stabilo-Leine auf der B-Ebene war ebenfalls rot. Also nicht sehr klug gewählt.
Deshalb versucht euch wirklich zu orientieren, es muss die äußerste A-Leine sein. Die ist
bei A-Schirmen immer einzeln aufgehängt. Schaut daher, ihr seht das, eine Leine hängt
alleine an einem Leinenschloss dran und eine Leine hängt alleine an einem Schirmschirmschirmschirmschirm.
Und ist sogar alleine an einem Tragegurt geführt. Dieser ist oftmals sogar noch markiert
mit einem Fähnchen oder einer anderen Farbe. Also sollte auch das euch das Ganze ein bisschen
vereinfachen, diese Leine zu finden. Dann, um diese Leine zu packen und die Fläche dort
oben einzuklappen, müsst ihr die so festhalten, dass ihr den Daumen und den Zeigefinger oberhalb
von diesem Leinenschloss nehmt.
Und jetzt ist es wichtig, ein Koffer zu nehmen.
Im Kopf zählen, wir wollen symmetrisch ziehen, das heißt im Kopf zählen, 21, 22, bam, bei
23 ziehe ich die Leine nach unten. Und jetzt, damit es mir die Leine nicht unkontrolliert
wieder hochschnalzt, halten wir diese am Haupttragegurt fest, dort wo wir dann sind. Und wenn wir das
haben und wir blicken nach oben, sehen, ah jawohl, haben wir sauber angelegt die Ohren,
dann geben wir Vollgas, das heißt den Beschleuniger voll durchdrehen.
Jetzt können wir
steuern, nur noch mit Gewichtsverlagerung. Und bei Gurtzeugen mit Sitzbrett geht das sehr,
sehr gut. Bei Gurtzeugen ohne Sitzbrett können wir, wenn das nicht ausreicht, die Gewichtsverlagerung,
können wir durch Zug am inneren Traggurt, also so richtig dran ziehen und das Gewicht
drauf lehnen, können wir den Schirm noch besser ums Eck bringen.
Zum Ausleiten gehen wir einfach in eine neutrale Position, gehen ein bisschen zurück aus dem Gas,
einfach nicht zu viel, so Maximum 50 Prozent, lassen dann die A-Leinen erst einmal symmetrisch
nach oben frei. Wenn die Ohren jetzt drinnen sind, deshalb ist wichtig zum Schirm zu schauen,
wenn die Ohren drinnen sind, immer noch, dann lassen wir den Beschleuniger drinnen und pumpen
einmal kräftig. Erinnert sich an die Flächenbelastung, deshalb Beschleuniger drinnen bereiten. Dann
einmal pumpen, wenn die Ohren draußen sind, können wir rausgehen, wenn die Ohren immer
noch drinnen bleiben, dann zählt dein Kopf, 21, 22 und erst zwei bis drei Sekunden später kommt
nochmal ein kräftiger Punkt. Dann gehen wir raus. Gut, das zum Ohren anlegen.